[Musique]
ce président qui se trouve que
représente aujourd'hui c'est une
nouvelle installation
elle représente 2500 m² de surface au
sol nous avons pu établir des ateliers
de fabrication qui sont mieux adaptés
aux besoins du personnel
nous avons un millier de producteurs de
lait dont nous collectons de sociétaires
c'est-à-dire dans nos collections dans
la haute-vienne une partie de la
dordogne un petit peu la corrèze
en principe nous allons je pense
collecté 7 en aidant les 38 millions de
litres de lait c'est je pense une gage
de sécurité et d'avenir pour nos
sociétaires pour nos producteurs de lait
c'est aussi un outil de travail pour le
personnel qui lui permet de travailler
dans une bonne position satisfaisante et
qui répond mesures d'hygiène de sécurité
nous avons joué d'abord la carte de la
sécurité
ensuite
bienvenue dans joue également la carte
de la productivité sachant que c'est un
élément essentiel aujourd'hui si on veut
qu'une industrie puisse survivre
l'homme effectivement joue un rôle
important et disons que son rôle a été
augmentée je veux dire que cette
nouvelle construction qui permet de
doubler notre production qui est une
garantie qu'amène pour la production
laitière de la région et des roulements
des consommateurs
actuellement nous avons la même quantité
de personnes
comparable aux objectifs maintenant bien
nos objectifs c'est de la saturer le
fabriquer au maximum pour bien sûr
produire garcia team indispensable si
nous souhaitons nous développer et
assurer notre rôle dans la région près
ce soit tant au coin des producteurs y
attendent
deux outils une bonne rentabilité de
leurs deux lors les que des
consommateurs qui souhaitent
trouver un produit
à proximité qu'ils soient sans reproche
[Musique]
m